One of the really difficult things about depression is that it can make even the smallest things feel enormous. Having a shower, getting dressed, going outside, replying to a message, even making yourself a cup of tea. And if you've been signed off work because you're depressed, you might suddenly find you have something you haven't had for a long while. But having more time doesn't necessarily mean you're automatically going to start feeling better. So today I'm going to give you five evidence.
抑郁症最困难的一点在于，它会让即使最微小的事情也显得无比沉重。洗个澡、穿衣服、出门、回复一条信息，甚至给自己泡杯茶。如果你因为抑郁而请了病假，你可能会突然发现自己拥有了很长一段时间都没有的东西。但拥有更多的时间并不一定意味着你会自动开始感觉好转。所以今天，我将为你提供五个基于证据的建议。
based things you can do in around a minute which might just start moving the needle on how you feel. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, a clinical psychologist and this is psychology actually. Before we get started I have one little request. I've noticed that many of you listening to or watching the show aren't yet following or subscribing. For example on YouTube over 93% of my regular long form viewers are not subscribed to the show. It's a really simple thing to do on YouTube. Go to my channel, click subscribe. It's totally free and it helps me to grow as a creator to get even better guests and to keep creating this content that I know you love. Thank you so much wherever you listen or watch the show. I love that you do and I love hearing
这些事情你可以在一分钟左右完成，它们或许能让你当下的感受产生一点点改变。我是临床心理学家玛丽安·特伦特博士，这是《心理学其实》。在开始之前，我有一个小小的请求。我注意到许多收听或观看本节目的朋友还没有关注或订阅。例如，在YouTube上，超过93%的长期固定观众并没有订阅本频道。在YouTube上订阅非常简单。去我的频道，点击订阅。这是完全免费的，它能帮助我作为创作者成长，邀请到更好的嘉宾，并继续创作我知道你们喜欢的内容。无论你在哪里收听或观看本节目，都非常感谢你。我喜欢你们这样做，也喜欢听到
from you too. Let's dive in with the content. Something I want to cover before we get into our techniques is the idea that, you know, when I feel better, then I'll start to do these things. I really want to kind of turn that on its head a little bit because what we know about the theory of behavioural activation is that often we will need to start doing some of the things before we actually feel motivated to do it. I know that sounds all out of whack, but it really is true. That action needs to come, even in small doses, before it will necessarily feel rewarding, which will then feel like you're motivated to do it. That's why we're starting really small today. And this, of course, is because depression itself means that you have a decrease in interest and
你们的反馈。让我们深入探讨一下内容。在进入具体技巧之前，我想先谈谈这样一个观念：你知道，很多人会想“等我感觉好点了，我再开始做这些事”。我真的很想颠覆这种想法，因为根据行为激活理论，我们往往需要先开始做一些事情，然后才会产生去做的动力。我知道这听起来很不合逻辑，但事实确实如此。行动需要先行，哪怕只是小剂量的行动，在它让你感到有回报之前，你才会觉得有动力去做。这就是为什么我们今天从非常小的事情开始。当然，这是因为抑郁症本身意味着你的兴趣和
motivation. You know, a lot of the things that you would usually do that make you feel like you are not happening right now. I love my chat with Professor Paul Gilbert and I love the way that compassion-focused therapy thinks about depression in that it kind of makes sense. We're kind of adjusting to the situation that feels outside of our control, feels overwhelming. And so depression is kind of, you know, our body's natural response to that situation we find ourselves in. And when we're in that state, it means that something like, oh, I'll just go out for a 45 minute walk can feel as difficult as if somebody said, why don't you go and climb a mountain. So that's why we're trying to get in there with our simple one minute techniques, which might just allow us to kind of sneak past without your brain going, oh no, no, no, that's not happening. And throughout this video, I'm going to make reference to some of my own experiences with lower mood.
动力会下降。你知道，很多你通常会做、让你感觉良好的事情，现在都无法进行了。我喜欢与保罗·吉尔伯特教授的对话，也喜欢“同情聚焦疗法”看待抑郁症的方式，因为它在某种程度上讲得通。我们是在适应一种感觉超出我们控制、令人不知所措的情况。所以，抑郁症可以说是我们身体对所处环境的一种自然反应。当我们处于那种状态时，意味着像“去散步45分钟”这样的事情，会感觉像有人让你去爬山一样困难。这就是为什么我们要尝试用这些简单的一分钟技巧切入，它们或许能让我们在你的大脑还没反应过来“哦不，不，不，这不可能”之前，悄悄地完成任务。在整个视频中，我也会提到我自己情绪低落时的一些经历。
For example, when I lost my dad in 2017 and I had a period of time off work. And some of the other times when I've really struggled. So I know what it's like to struggle. I am a human. I'm always a human first, a psychologist, second. I'm a mum too. I'm a wife. I'm a friend.
例如，2017年我父亲去世时，我有一段时间没去工作。还有其他一些我感到非常挣扎的时刻。所以我知道挣扎是什么感觉。我是一个人。我首先是一个人，其次才是一名心理学家。我也是一位母亲。我是一位妻子。我是一位朋友。
You know, I've got people in my life who've struggled with depression and we all struggle with our mood from time to time. So let's get into it. Number one. clean something. Clean anything. It could be you. It could be that you're diving into the shower for the world's quickest one minute shower. It could be that you're going to wash your face. It could be that you're going to brush your teeth. It could be that you're going to encourage your dog or your cat to freshen up. It could be that you're going to do the washing up for one minute.
你知道，我的生活中也有人曾与抑郁症作斗争，我们所有人偶尔都会为情绪而苦恼。所以，让我们开始吧。第一点：清理某样东西。清理任何东西。可以是清理你自己。也许是冲进浴室，进行世界上最快的一分钟淋浴。也许是洗把脸。也许是刷刷牙。也许是鼓励你的狗或猫梳理一下毛发。也许是花一分钟洗碗。
You're just going to fill up the bowl, you know, get it done or you're going to stack the dishwasher. You're going to make that happen. You're going to choose. one thing to clean in one minute. It might even be just changing your clothes and looking at what you're wearing thinking right yeah it's been a few days. I'm going to pick something clean out of my cupboards, maybe I'm going to change my pants, maybe I'm going to change my socks, I'm just going to freshen up how I feel. And I think this is a really powerful one because when it comes to keeping ourselves clean it can snowball really quickly. I know when I've got clean hair and I'm feeling like I'm well put together,
你只需要把水槽装满，把它洗完，或者把洗碗机装好。你要让这件事发生。你要选择一件可以在一分钟内清理的东西。甚至可能只是换掉衣服，看看自己身上穿的，心想“没错，确实已经好几天了”。我要从柜子里拿件干净的衣服，也许换条裤子，也许换双袜子，我只是想让自己感觉清爽一点。我认为这非常有效，因为当我们保持个人卫生时，它会产生滚雪球效应。我知道当我头发干净、感觉自己打理得很好时，
I'm more likely to say yes to opportunities. Whereas on the days where I haven't washed my hair for days and it's in a greasy bun on top of my head, I haven't got any makeup on, maybe I've got tomato sauce all down my top like I did yesterday. My husband pointed out, I'm perhaps less likely to feel good about myself. And so, yeah, having the chance to maybe put that tomato those sauce top in the wash. And then, you know, do something nice with my hair. If I have the energy to do that, does mean that I'm starting to beat that kind of self-fulfilling,
我更有可能接受各种机会。而那些我好几天没洗头、头发在头顶扎成油腻发髻的日子，我没化妆，衣服上可能还沾着番茄酱——就像我昨天那样。我丈夫指了出来，我可能就不太容易对自己感觉良好。所以，有机会把那件沾了番茄酱的衣服洗掉，然后，你知道，把头发打理一下，如果我有精力的话，确实意味着我开始打破那种自我实现的、
kind of entrenched pattern, which keeps me stuck for longer. We absolutely aren't saying we're changing everything. We are just saying, what could I do in 60 seconds that might clean myself or clean something else just to give me that little bit of a bump start? And I know that when we're off work, when we're signed off work for depression, low mood, stress, it means that sometimes some of the usual kind of routines that might keep us feeling, certainly more functional, do slip away. So just thinking about what that one minute of cleaning, self or something else might help you to start to grease the wheels, just to help get a little bit more flexibility, a little bit more movement into your day.
根深蒂固的模式，那种模式让我长期陷入困境。我们绝对不是说要改变一切。我们只是在说，我能在60秒内做些什么来清理自己或清理其他东西，从而给自己一个启动的动力？我知道当我们因为抑郁、情绪低落、压力而请病假时，有时一些能让我们保持功能性的日常习惯会逐渐消失。所以，只需考虑那一分钟的清理——无论是清理自己还是其他东西——可能有助于你开始润滑齿轮，让你的生活多一点灵活性，多一点活力。
Just to help today look a little bit different than yesterday did. So a really simple one minute might just be changing out of your pyjamas, putting on maybe a pair of joggers, a t-shirt, brushing your teeth, one minute. That distinction between daytime you and nighttime you can be really powerful. Strategy number two is to go outside. We're not talking about that trip up the mountain. We are small. We are opening the door. We are maybe taking something to the bin in your guard.
只是为了让今天看起来和昨天有点不同。所以，一个非常简单的一分钟任务可能就是换掉睡衣，穿上一条慢跑裤、一件T恤，刷刷牙，只需一分钟。白天状态的你和夜晚状态的你之间的那种区别是非常强大的。第二个策略是出门。我们说的不是去爬山。我们要做的是小事。我们打开门。我们可能只是把垃圾拿到花园的垃圾桶里，
or your yard or on your street. We are maybe just walking, you know, one minute up your street or 30 seconds up your street and then 30 seconds back. We are maybe talking about going into the garden and just seeing what you can see, maybe seeing what season has changed and what changes have been happening since you were last there. What we're trying to do is we're trying to get
或者院子里，或者街道上。我们可能只是沿着街道走一分钟，或者走30秒再走回来。我们可能只是走进花园，看看能看到什么，也许看看季节有什么变化，自上次去那里以来发生了什么变化。我们试图做的是，我们试图让
a little bit of daylight into our lives. And I appreciate that and if you've got some additional physical health needs or disabilities that actually getting outside, especially if you're by yourself, might feel more challenging. In that case, maybe get closer to a window or move yourself to a different room, have a little bit of a different vista, even if I'm working from home, sometimes in the morning I will be in this study, in the afternoon I might go and sit in a different area of the house just to get kind of a little bit of of movement into my day.
我们的生活中多一点日光。我理解，如果你有额外的身体健康需求或残疾，出门——尤其是当你独自一人时——可能会感到更具挑战性。在这种情况下，也许靠近窗户，或者移动到另一个房间，换个视野。即使我在家工作，有时早上我会在这间书房，下午我可能会去房子的另一个区域坐坐，只是为了让我的生活多一点点变动。
And we're not necessarily talking about going out and having exercise at this point. I think this is sometimes vastly beyond where you might feel like you can start. We are literally just talking about one minute of changing your space, ideally involving some fresh air outside, a little bit of sunlight on your face,
我们此时并不一定是在谈论出去锻炼。我认为这有时远远超出了你觉得可以开始的程度。我们实际上只是在谈论一分钟的改变空间，最好是包含一些户外的清新空气，一点阳光照在脸上，
just changing your vista, changing your perspective from those same four walls that you've been used to seeing. I remember that the dirtiest I've ever been is when I had my children and they were very little. And I was breastfeeding at the time and so I was being woken multiple times a day.
只是改变你的视野，改变你对那四面墙的视角，因为你已经习惯了看它们。我记得我最邋遢的时候是我生孩子的时候，那时他们还很小。我当时在母乳喂养，所以每天晚上都要醒来好几次。
And I was obviously keeping my children clean and fresh and in kind of nice clean clothes and bathed at the end of the day. But really, me and another one of my friends, we used to often have one shower a week where we'd go and take our children swimming and then she and I would take our shampoo, we'd take our conditioner, we'd take a body puff and the kids would sit on the shower floor as we had what we were calling a spa-like experience. Like parenting is really hard and I found
我显然把孩子们照顾得很干净、清爽，给他们穿上干净的衣服，每天晚上给他们洗澡。但实际上，我和我的另一个朋友，我们过去常常每周洗一次澡，我们会带孩子去游泳，然后她和我带着洗发水、护发素、沐浴球，孩子们坐在淋浴间的地板上，我们享受着所谓的“水疗体验”。为人父母真的很辛苦，我发现
that I certainly lost quite a lot of myself. I wouldn't say that I had postnatal depression, but I certainly lost a lot of the usual things that I would do that made me feel like Marianne. And actually having clean hair makes me feel good and makes me just feel more like myself. So, yeah, the second time around, I definitely tried to make time to have a shower, to do something different. And if you've got kind of caring responsibilities, it might mean that you're going to have to ask for help a little bit as well. Could you come and sit with, you know, my mother-in-law, my father-in-law, my mom, my dad, my husband, who's not well, my child, whilst I have this kind of one minute freshen up, or whether you can kind of, if they're young enough, if they're a child, you can get them safe or have them so that they're asleep and then choose your one minute to get yourself clean. We can do this. And when we're off work, especially if we usually would go out to work, it can be that latched. of routine, that lack of structure, which feels like you've suddenly got this great big yawning stretch of a day, but I know sometimes that's really easy to feel, perhaps with things
我确实失去了很多自我。我不会说我患有产后抑郁症，但我确实失去了很多我通常会做、让我感觉自己是玛丽安的事情。实际上，头发干净让我感觉良好，让我感觉更像我自己。所以，第二次的时候，我绝对尝试挤出时间洗澡，做些不同的事情。如果你有照顾他人的责任，这可能意味着你还得寻求一点帮助。能不能请人——比如我的婆婆、公公、妈妈、爸爸、生病的丈夫、孩子——帮我照看一会儿，让我有一分钟的时间梳洗一下？或者，如果他们足够小，如果是孩子，你可以确保他们安全，或者等他们睡着了，然后选择你的一分钟来清理自己。我们可以做到。当我们请病假时，尤其是如果我们通常会外出工作，那种缺乏常规、缺乏结构的感觉，会让你觉得突然拥有了一大段漫长的时间，但我知道有时这很容易被填满，也许是用那些
that aren't feeling like they're that helpful or supportive of your mental health right now. So we're just going to find that one minute in the day to change your vista, to change your perspective, to get out, fresh air, breathe it in. you're allowed to come back inside again. Number three, we are going to be interacting with another living thing. Now when I was home all the time with my kids when they were little, sometimes it was like, oh obviously yes you're a living thing but you can't talk and you cry a lot and it's feeling hard work. One of my favorite things to do because we don't have pets at home but one of my favorite things to do was go out to the local pet shop which we could get to by walking and we'd go and look
现在感觉对你的心理健康没有太大帮助或支持的事情。所以我们只是要在一天中找到那一分钟来改变你的视野，改变你的视角，走出去，呼吸新鲜空气。你完全可以再回到室内。第三点，我们要与另一个生命体互动。当我还是全职妈妈，孩子们还小的时候，有时会觉得，哦，当然，你是生命体，但你不会说话，而且经常哭，感觉很辛苦。我最喜欢做的事情之一——因为我们家里没有宠物——就是去当地的宠物店，我们可以步行到达，我们会去看
at the fish and actually giving us both the chance to focus on something else something separate was really nice and one of my children really really like dogs so when we're in the pet shop we would often see dogs but when you're choosing your something or some things that are other than yourself to interact with. It might be that you've got a pet nearby or your neighbor has one or on your one minute kind of walking about out and about if you see a dog, you know, if you see a bird, could you observe that? Could you interact with it? What could you do that helps you feel connected to something else other than just yourself? It might be, you know, just saying hi to someone in a shop if you happen to be there. It might be, you know, sending someone a voice note, sending a message to someone.
鱼。实际上，给我们俩一个机会去关注别的东西、独立的东西，真的很不错。我的一个孩子非常非常喜欢狗，所以当我们在宠物店时，我们经常会看到狗。但当你选择除了自己以外的某个人或某些东西来互动时，可能是你附近有宠物，或者你的邻居有宠物，或者在你那一分钟的散步中，如果你看到一只狗，你知道，如果你看到一只鸟，你能观察它吗？你能与它互动吗？你能做些什么来帮助你感到与除了自己以外的东西有联系？可能是，你知道，在商店里和某人打个招呼（如果你碰巧在那里的话）。可能是，你知道，给某人发一条语音信息，给某人发条信息。
It might be having a quick phone call with someone just to check in with them. But I understand that with depression, sometimes that can all feel too much. So we're starting really small. In what way can you spend one minute interacting with something else? The point is here to kind of get some stimulation, some interaction with something outside of what's going. on inside your head because that can feel like an echo chamber at times. Of course, if you are off work at the moment, then it might be that interactions with your colleagues usually would feel a big part of your day or you might be like, couldn't stand them anyway. It's better without them. But there might be some of your colleagues that you do still like, value, trust, you know,
可能是和某人打个简短的电话，只是为了问候一下。但我明白，抑郁症有时会让这一切感觉太沉重。所以我们从非常小的事情开始。你以什么方式可以花一分钟与别的东西互动？这里的重点是获得一些刺激，与你脑子里正在发生的事情之外的东西进行互动，因为那有时会感觉像是一个回声室。当然，如果你现在没去工作，那么与同事的互动通常会感觉是你一天中很大的一部分，或者你可能会想，“反正也受不了他们，没有他们更好”。但可能仍有一些你确实喜欢、重视、信任的同事，你知道，
even miss from your life. So could you check in with them if you wanted to? And whilst social media can make it feel like we are connected to other people, I want to try and encourage you to try and connect with people you actually do know, people that you have previously spent time with, people that are or have been an important part of your life, because social media can sometimes fuel some of the way that we feel about ourselves. So we're just striving for that one minute of connection with a real, other, living, breathing, person, animal, creature, bird, something. Okay? I would love to know how you're doing with this. Do let me know in the comments. Okay, and our fourth tip is complete
甚至在生活中想念他们。所以如果你愿意，可以联系他们吗？虽然社交媒体会让我们觉得我们与他人有联系，但我希望能鼓励你尝试与你真正认识的人联系，那些你以前花过时间相处的人，那些是或曾经是你生活中重要一部分的人，因为社交媒体有时会加剧我们对自己感受的负面影响。所以我们只是在争取那一分钟与一个真实的、其他的、活着的、呼吸的人、动物、生物、鸟类或其他东西的连接。好吗？我很想知道你做得怎么样。请在评论区告诉我。好的，我们的第四个技巧是完成
one tiny task. Now, you might be really good at generating a big, huge list of things that you could do, and you look at those and you're like, nope, nope, nope, nope. Nope, we're going really small. It might be that the clothes that you took off earlier, you put those in the washing machine. Get them washed. It might be that you open any post you've had today. It might be that you book the appointment that's been on your mind that you need to book. It might be that you reply to a text message, WhatsApp message from someone who's checking in with you.
一件微小的任务。现在，你可能非常擅长列出一大堆你可以做的事情，然后你看着它们，心想“不，不，不，不”。不，我们要从非常小的事情开始。可能是你早些时候脱下的衣服，把它们放进洗衣机。把它们洗了。可能是打开你今天收到的任何邮件。可能是预约那个一直挂在你心头、你需要预约的医生。可能是回复某条正在关心你的短信或WhatsApp信息。
I know when it comes to being off sick from work, sometimes it can feel like you've got, you know, HR calls to do or people to keep notified or sending in your kind of fitness note, it might be that that's the task that you can choose to do today, just a really small one-minute task. And I really want you to think about focusing on trying to complete that task. So that's why we're starting really small here, because depression, of course, can leave things feeling unfinished and unproductive. So we want to pick a small little thing that you can do, that kind of gets something done, has that sense of achievement, and again, has today look a little bit different than it did yesterday. It's maybe not sorting out the kitchen,
我知道当因为生病而请假时，有时会感觉你有很多HR电话要打，或者要通知别人，或者要提交你的病假条。可能这就是你今天可以选择完成的任务，仅仅是一个非常小的一分钟任务。我真的希望你专注于尝试完成那个任务。这就是为什么我们从非常小的事情开始，因为抑郁症当然会让事情感觉未完成且效率低下。所以我们想挑选一件你可以做的小事，这能让你完成某件事，获得那种成就感，并且再次让今天看起来和昨天有点不同。也许不是整理厨房，
it's maybe just washing up, you know, four plates. So when we're doing something, when we're completing something, it gives ourselves that satisfying sense of mastery, something that we've achieved. Even yesterday, I was thinking about tackling an entire draw that's just full of junk and probably all needs to go,
也许只是洗四个盘子。所以当我们做某事时，当我们完成某事时，它会给我们一种令人满意的掌控感，一种我们已经实现的东西。即使是昨天，我也在想清理一个装满杂物、可能都需要扔掉的抽屉，
but it's really challenging, isn't it? So I thought, I'm just gonna pick five things out of this drawer and I'm gonna put them in a bag and I put them in my car boot and then take them to the charity shop. Just five small things. It literally took me a minute. Get that done. But yeah, you pick your one minute of something that you can complete
但这真的很有挑战性，不是吗？所以我心想，我只从这个抽屉里挑五样东西，把它们放进袋子里，然后放到我的车后备箱里，带去慈善商店。仅仅五件小事。这实际上只花了我一分钟。把它做完。但没错，挑选你那一分钟可以完成的事情，
that will help you to start to make that shift. And our fifth and final technique is treating yourself purposefully, deliberately. And treating yourself doesn't always look like a massive cash splurge on something. It can just be something that you, know about yourself that you really like. So I've got a favourite blanket and I like to snuggle into that. I've got a favourite mug as well. It might be that you're going to give yourself permission to make yourself your favourite cup of tea or to, you know, have a hot chocolate that you really like, drink it in your favourite mug. For me, music is really powerful and important to me.
这将有助于你开始做出改变。我们的第五个也是最后一个技巧是：有目的、有意识地善待自己。善待自己并不总是意味着在某件事上挥霍一大笔钱。它可能只是你了解自己真正喜欢的东西。我有一条最喜欢的毯子，我喜欢蜷缩在里面。我还有一个最喜欢的杯子。可能你会允许自己给自己泡一杯最喜欢的茶，或者，你知道，喝一杯你真正喜欢的热巧克力，用你最喜欢的杯子喝。对我来说，音乐非常强大且重要。
It might be that it is for you too or that it has been in the past. What track could you put on that might help boost your mood or help you feel like, oh, yeah, this is a good song for me. Like this really speaks to me and it helps me to feel like myself again. And after we've done that thing, or even when we're in that moment, perhaps when we're having that lovely hot chocolate, we've got our hands around that cup, I really want you to think about how I'm feeling, or maybe if you're doing it after the event, How did I feel when I was doing that?
可能对你来说也是如此，或者过去曾经是。你可以播放什么曲目来帮助提升你的情绪，或者让你觉得“哦，没错，这是一首适合我的歌”。这真的触动了我，它帮助我感觉自己又找回了自己。在我们做完那件事之后，或者甚至当我们处于那一刻时——也许当我们喝着那杯可爱的热巧克力，双手捧着杯子时——我真的希望你思考一下我的感受，或者如果你是在事后做，我在做那件事时感觉如何？
What did I notice about myself, my thoughts, my feelings? How did my body feel when I was doing that thing? I think depression can be really especially sneaky because it can make us entirely devoid of self-care. When in actual fact, what we know is when we're at our best, we're likely to be engaging regularly in self-care. Self-care doesn't always look like massages and facials and manicures, It absolutely doesn't. It just looks like spending a little bit of time doing something that you know
我注意到了关于我自己的什么？我的想法、我的感受？我在做那件事时身体感觉如何？我认为抑郁症可能特别狡猾，因为它会让我们完全缺乏自我关怀。而实际上，我们所知道的是，当我们处于最佳状态时，我们很可能会定期进行自我关怀。自我关怀并不总是看起来像按摩、面部护理和美甲，绝对不是。它看起来只是花一点点时间做一些你知道
that will help you to feel different or better. And I really want to reinforce the idea that self-care isn't selfish. It's essential. It's that idea of when you're on an aeroplane, you've got to put your own gas mask on first because, of course, what we know is that when we are at our best, we are more able to be equipped to help others more too. That is absolutely the science of it. So you're allowed to care for yourself. In fact, I would really urge you to. I really want to have a little look at something that I did last week when I had time off work and compare and contrast for how that might change depending how often we do these things. So I'm usually working or I've got stuff to do with the kids or I'm cooking or I'm, you know, doing all the mum things or the running my own
会帮助你感觉不同或更好的事情。我真的想强化这样一个观念：自我关怀不是自私。它是必不可少的。就像飞机上的那个想法，你必须先戴上自己的氧气面罩，因为当然，我们知道，当我们处于最佳状态时，我们更有能力去帮助他人。这绝对是科学依据。所以你被允许照顾自己。事实上，我真的强烈建议你这样做。我真的想回顾一下我上周请假时做的事情，并对比一下这取决于我们做这些事情的频率，它可能会如何改变。所以我通常在工作，或者我有孩子的事情要处理，或者我在做饭，或者我在，你知道，做所有妈妈的事情，或者经营我自己的
business things. So I rarely get the chance to watch the BBC show called Homes Under the Hammer or the ITV show with Ben Shepard called Tipping Point. I really do really like those shows. And so because I had some time off last week, I spent time, you know, watching those and really, really enjoyed it as a bit of a mindful treat, as a little bit of self-futable. care to myself, but actually if I had just this gaping chasm of time in my day and all I was doing was watching homes under the hammer in the morning and tipping point in the afternoon, that might continue to kind of perpetuate the way I'm feeling. So I really want you to think about whether the things you're doing are actually making you feel any better. So if you're
生意。所以我很少有机会看BBC的节目《Homes Under the Hammer》或者本·谢泼德主持的ITV节目《Tipping Point》。我真的很喜欢这些节目。所以因为我上周有时间休息，我花时间看了这些节目，并真正地、真正地享受它，把它当作一种正念的款待，作为对自己的一点点自我关怀。但实际上，如果我的一天中只有这种巨大的时间空洞，而我所做的只是早上看《Homes Under the Hammer》，下午看《Tipping Point》，那可能会继续延续我现在的感受。所以我真的希望你思考一下你正在做的事情是否真的让你感觉好转了。所以如果你
sleeping away the afternoon, how is that making you feel and how is that impacting on sleep, of course, later that day. So let's just have a little bit of an audit about whether the way that you are spending your time is enriching it. So we're just having a little check-in. So this isn't a video of me saying make better use of your sick leave. Sick leave is there for a reason. It's there because you're not currently well enough to do the job that you do and that you need that time to look after yourself. Maybe even sort out some of the life factors that you've got to stabilize things to make it more likely that you're going to thrive again in your role and in all of the roles that you do as well because we're not just saying
在下午睡觉，那让你感觉如何？那对当天晚些时候的睡眠有什么影响？所以让我们对你度过时间的方式是否在丰富你的生活进行一点审计。所以我们只是做一个小小的检查。所以这不是一个让我说“更好地利用你的病假”的视频。病假是有原因的。它存在是因为你目前身体状况不足以胜任你的工作，你需要时间来照顾自己。也许甚至整理一下你生活中需要稳定的因素，以增加你再次在你的角色中茁壮成长的可能性，以及你在所有角色中都能茁壮成长的可能性，因为我们不是说
that you're not well enough for work although sometimes if it's a workplace you know situation that's that's led to your depression that might well just feel like it's a bit more contained to work but really what we know about depression is that we're not really well enough to do many of the things that we would usually do in our day and our life so yeah, we're not saying maximise this sick leave. This is not what this video, this episode is about. We're just trying to think about giving a natural kind of skeleton, a structure to your day, really trying to use those five simple things to help make a difference. And before we finish, I really want to think about how depression can make us think in these all or nothing terms, you know?
你不能胜任工作，尽管有时如果是一个工作场所的情况导致了你的抑郁，那可能确实感觉更局限于工作。但实际上，关于抑郁症我们所知道的是，我们确实没有足够的精力去做我们日常生活中通常会做的许多事情。所以没错，我们不是说要最大化利用病假。这不是这个视频、这一集的主题。我们只是试图考虑给你的生活提供一个自然的骨架，一种结构，真正尝试利用那五个简单的事情来帮助产生改变。在我们结束之前，我真的想思考一下抑郁症如何让我们以这种“非黑即白”的方式思考，你知道吗？
If I can't clean up the whole house, if I can't clean up the whole kitchen, then what's the point? You can also make us think about what you might be missing out on at work and what other people might be getting ahead on and what you're losing out on. I really want to quiet some of that noise if we can. And again, when we're thinking about reaching out to friends, it's like, oh, well, I'm not very good company. So why would I reach out to somebody at all? Let's not forget that in relationships, there is give and there is take. It might be that in the past you've always given, give and given, given. like a bank, okay?
如果我不能打扫整个房子，如果我不能打扫整个厨房，那还有什么意义？它还可以让我们思考你在工作中可能错过了什么，别人可能在取得什么进展，以及你正在失去什么。如果可以的话，我真的想让那些噪音安静下来。同样，当我们考虑联系朋友时，会想“哦，我不是一个很好的陪伴者”。所以我为什么要联系别人呢？别忘了在人际关系中，有给予也有索取。可能在过去你总是给予、给予、给予。就像银行一样，好吗？
We have to allow ourselves to draw out on those deposits sometimes as well. It's all part of that self-care, but also part of kind of self-belief and self-worth. Borrow from others, draw down on those deposits and know that that's okay. And when you're well enough, you'll be able to feed back into that and support others again too. Sometimes recovery from depression really does begin with just this series of very ordinary things. And it's not because something like brushing your teeth cures your depression, it doesn't. But it's that conscious re-entering of your own life, taking control, even just a little bit of control, day by day, which starts to make the difference.
我们有时也必须允许自己从那些存款中提取。这都是自我关怀的一部分，也是自我信念和自我价值的一部分。向他人借力，提取那些存款，并知道这样做是可以的。当你状态足够好时，你将能够回馈并再次支持他人。有时从抑郁症中恢复确实始于这一系列非常普通的事情。这并不是因为像刷牙这样的事情能治愈你的抑郁症，它不能。但这是你对自己生活的有意识的重新进入，掌控——哪怕只是一点点掌控——日复一日，这才是开始产生差异的地方。
I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. I hope you've really enjoyed this episode of psychology, actually. I'd love to know what you think. If you like this episode, I think you'll also really like the episode I mentioned earlier with Professor Paul Giles. which is all about compassion and how we can use that to make a real difference for the way that you feel. The details will be on screen or in the show notes. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我希望你真的很喜欢这一集的《心理学其实》。我很想知道你的想法。如果你喜欢这一集，我想你也会非常喜欢我之前提到的与保罗·吉尔斯教授的那一集，那一集全是关于同情心以及我们如何利用它来真正改变你的感受。详细信息将在屏幕上或节目说明中显示。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。